there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make hundred percent halal raw
cat food there are countless health
benefits to this new raw diet check them
out on instagram at alif dot uk they do
monthly subscription boxes and you can
get 10 discount on their two week trial
box with my code ali10 check them out
now and let your cat enjoy some nice
food
detroit urban survival training i'm
going to share with you right now what
to do
if a striker fired weapon is pinning
against your chest against the wall in
this case it's striker fire so there's
no hammer in the back so the first i'm
going to do since we can't move out of
the way we can't move off line and if i
were to try to move this as soon as he
saw my hand move he's going to fire so
we have to make this weapons not fire
and give an example to human reaction
time when he sees me move he's gonna
fire
so the reason why it didn't move the
slide didn't slide is because i
inhibited it by pushing it to the rear
from that from there what we do is push
the barrel back towards the aggressor
and now you have the weapon this is dawa
style protections
let's get on with it so somebody points
a gun out to you
okay it's a bb gun not a real gun the
first thing you do is say excuse me
sister one second let go
okay
you can hold it okay
yeah just make sure so you're in a
threatening position you have to make
sure the gun is clean yeah it's got a
little smudge there
let's see okay there we go and
there's a few things as anyone should do
not muslim non-muslim it's number one if
someone's got a gun to you yes
give everything up give everything up
take it you know take my toyota prius
you know take
why are you shooting bro i'm giving you
everything
if you feel what please yeah would you
be gone if you feel your life is in
danger or your family's life's in danger
and you know this person is going to
kill obviously everyone deserves the
right to try to protect themselves get
the gun off disarm the person et cetera
in a legal way of course yeah depending
on country that the country what legal
stands for what's real protection now
brahmana says jokes aside um and
subhanallah we should be very careful
with this kind of stuff as well so panel
if someone has a real gun don't try to
you know these techniques etc these kung
fu monsters whatever that may be it can
cost you your life allah subhanahu talah
we are muslims and we believe in the
supernatural world we look for all kind
of protection against things that we
might be harmed by by crossing the road
look left to right we're a knifeproof
vest bulletproof vest all these kind of
things because we see physical harms
allah subhanahu wa tala is telling us
there is metaphysical harms the
metaphysical world that exists so there
is the afghan which i'm going to give
you guys one says every muslim should do
this you can be harmed of course
physically as well we believe it
protects you from physical harm as well
unless what allah will and the
metaphysical world which we believe in
evil eye
and magic and whatever it may be
brothers and sisters inshallah we
believe in the metaphysical world of
jinns and satan etc to protect you so
one of them is
okay so which is in the name of allah by
his name nothing can cause harm neither
on earth nor in the heaven and he is all
hearing the all knowing that is one that
you should recite free time the other
one is
[Music]
which means oh allah i seek your
forgiveness and your protection in this
world and in the next oh allah i see you
i seek your forgiveness and your
protection in my religion in my worldly
affairs in my family and my wealth o
allah consume my secrets and preserve me
from anguish oh allah god guide me from
what is in front of me and behind me
from my left and from my right and from
above me i seek refuge in your greatness
from being struck down from beneath me
yes another one is
i seek refuge in allah allah's perfect
words from the evil he has created and
it goes on brothers and sisters this is
the real protection from the muslim for
a believer to do inshallah and protect
yourself from all kinds of things it is
highly recommended by sisters every
single one of us to do this subhan allah
like allah says from the evil that he
has created we believe allah subhana wa
has created things that can harm us and
we seek protection from him rather than
the stupid belief of thinking that allah
has created something that might harm us
therefore that means allah has harmed us
no it doesn't work uh but anyways until
next time brother sisters look out for
yourselves inshallah be careful keep
safe keep things legal inshallah until
next time